The Foundation once tried to kill SCP-682,
the Hard to Destroy Reptile, with SCP-272,
an old iron nail.
This anomalous nail can kill its victims in
a number of ways: The nail bind’s a victim’s
shadow to the ground, indirectly binding the
victim itself as well by doing so.
If the shadow is displaced due to changes
in light source, the victim is flung and contorted
in the same direction the shadow has moved.
If the victim tries to destroy the nail, they
will surely die.
After the Foundation intentionally made the
lights in 682’s chamber strobe on and off
from various directions, causing the reptile
to be mutilated by being hurled around the
room.
Its body began producing an extremely powerful
light source, eliminating its own shadow and
keeping it safe.
The light was so bright that when D-Classes
entered the chamber to remove the nail - despite
wearing eye protection - they were afflicted
with permanent retinal damage.
And of course - in the end - SCP-682 was just
fine.